flip mino cool everybody it's gary
vaynerchuck and you know i was just
sitting here sorry i just got finished
taping my tequila episode are we sitting
at my computer and I just realized like
a lot of people ask me a lot about
business questions like how do you build
your brand how do you build your
business how'd you get that how did you
build a 50 million dollar wine shop how
did the show get so big it did it I
realized something that I I'm really
taken aback by and I think it's one of
the fundamental ground you know
foundations of building any business or
doing any entrepreneurial venture and
that is the statement of this video the
statement that I live by it's better
than zero I think way too many people
are always going so global in their mind
when's it gonna happen lack of patience
right I think when you're building
something even when you know you're big
I think about you know when I built the
wine shop when I built the wine show
when I've done other things in business
in my mind you know I was Oprah I was
you know Facebook I was Google I was you
know the Jets I was it I did my thing I
knew what I had in my DNA I knew what I
had in my skillset I knew what I brought
to the table but the world didn't the
world in it right mom watch here forget
RV trip Compton it's fun you know um the
world didn't know who I was and I had to
earn it and even though I already built
this 50 million dollar business in the
liquor store industry when I got to the
web 2.0 space to video content nobody
gave a crap right nobody cares that
you're a big-time lawyer nobody cares
that you sold off this you've got a
Reaper knit and when you're reading it
and you've already done well or if
you've come from nothing one or two the
two extremes it's very hard to take
minor victories but that is the key to
success you know getting one little link
I still do things now that are below me
that a lot of people in my market a lot
of people are like why do you answer
every email why do you do that you know
my friend Andre Mack just had a baby
it's awesome anyway why do i why do why
why would you do why would you agree to
do that blog post people always ask me
that why are you guest blogging on a
site that's a three million Alexa
because everything is better than zero
right
your
he's going to put a price on your time
and that's what you're giving up when
you're hustling but when you're building
a business when you're trying to build
something that you want to retire on or
you want to do this full time I'm going
to New Media Expo in Vegas this week
everyone's gonna be like yeah I want to
do this full time I do this
but it's what I want to do full time if
you want to do it full time you've got
to understand two principles Mott's
getting crazy I'm getting mob pumped up
it's this patience and you've got to
build your ass off and it's gonna take a
long time you gotta just keep building
and grinding in the building and two
everything is better than zero
just get your extra links get talked
about get a deal take five bucks instead
of ten bucks even though it's worth 10
bucks in every other market get $100
sponsorship of your show even though
your buddies are getting a thousand and
they're getting less views you
understand get what you can get take it
grab it everything is better than zero
and you know what if you keep pounding
away with that if you put your head down
and Ram Manatee man-style over and over
and over taking little pieces little
squirrel-like moves like an ant at the
end of the day you look around and
you've got something and you start
leveraging what you've got around you to
build to the next spot and then you
leverage again so everything everything
is better than zero and the way you
build on that is by hustling your face
off